en el día de la independencia de
colombia decenas de coronas en el
monumento a los héroes de bogotá hasta
sumar 74 el número de víctimas mortales
por la violencia registrada por
organizaciones humanitarias en el marco
del paro nacional son demasiados los que
tenemos que hacerle el homenaje y mis
manos no alcanzaron y decidieron unirse
para para poder llegar a este homenaje
porque todos merecen una ofrenda floral
este martes se vivió la reactivación del
paro nacional iniciado el pasado 28 de
abril la mayoría de marchas fueron
pacíficas y tuvieron una participación
diversa desde jóvenes hasta madres de
'falsos positivos' jóvenes ejecutados
extrajudicialmente y siento ese dolor
siento como si fuera la mamá de todos
estos jóvenes la abuela de todos estos
jóvenes también hubo presencia de la
primera línea en los últimos días han
estado en el centro de la polémica la
policía ha denunciado que las guerrillas
estarían detrás los jóvenes lo niegan
nosotros somos la primera línea que
cuida a un país entero en descontento
nosotros no somos creadores de violencia
otros simplemente respondemos al ataque
las fuerzas públicas por la mañana del
comité nacional de embargo que agrupa
sindicatos y organizaciones sociales
lidera una marcha y ante la nueva
legislatura del congreso que inició
también el martes va a radicar diez
proyectos de ley con propuestas como
renta básica educación gratuita y
reforma policial a la vez estamos
llamando a la totalidad del congreso y
al propio gobierno a respaldar y
convertir en políticas públicas esos
reclamos que la gente ha venido haciendo
en las calles de colombia
[Música]
el gobierno aprovechó la instalación del
congreso para erradicar la polémica
reforma tributaria es el segundo intento
el primero produjo la respuesta del 28
de abril en esta ocasión el 69% de
impuestos serán recaudados de las
empresas